pues efectivamente fue el comité
ejecutivo de los republicanos que se
estuvo reunido durante varias horas y
esa reunión que comenzó en la mañana
solamente terminó ya en la tarde de este
martes la idea era saber si iban a hacer
algún tipo de alianza para las
legislativas con el partido la república
en marcha que es el partido de manuela
mccomb había digamos él no había mucho
consenso acerca de esto pero el término
de esta reunión dieron a conocer que
finalmente habían votado de manera
unánime que ellos lo que quieren es un
partido que sea independiente que sea un
grupo parlamentario independiente así
que no van a hacer ningún tipo de
alianza sin embargo a pesar de que
dijeron que había sido unánime pues hubo
dos diputados que se abstuvieron de
votar y al término de esta reunión pues
hubo uno de los diputados que a la
prensa le dijo de un poco con una manera
un poco sarcástica que finalmente quizás
iba a haber dos de estos republicanos
que iban a terminar como ministros para
el final de esta semana y luego pues
también están las negociaciones entre
los verdes y
la francia y sumisa que es el partido de
melón - aunque quiere que estas
coaliciones de izquierda tomen una
fuerza importante para que él puede
hacer primer ministro ese es su gran
ambición sin embargo por ahora pues la
verdad es que entre los verdes no hay
tampoco digamos una
unidad acerca de lo que quieren hacer y
aniquilado el candidato de los verdes
dijo pues que no estaba muy seguro de
querer estar digamos recibiendo órdenes
por parte de meloso en todo caso tanto
los verdes como la francia insumisas se
reúnen el día de mañana